Oh
[Music]
the anti basilica I would've deflected a
beam
[Music]
some things you just can't get rid of a
bomb
[Music]
toward johnny-bro
while having them tell me
[Music]
their wardrobe master Jam camp for a
week or two before we started filming
with the costume to make sure that it
was really slight now and that
everything fit well and moved well and
whatever and i thought i thought jammed
and a wonderful job the jan camp and the
others involved tried to make the
costume as close to what was happening
in the comic books as they could being
somewhat ill-at-ease came from what's
going to happen when I put on that
costume and I walk on this stage another
grown man and these guys the crew what
are they going to do this is the end of
me they're going to make such fun you
know what happened at a dressing room on
the stage I took a deep breath
you know just to the costume took a deep
breath opened the door and walked across
the stage in character toward the lights
toward the camera and on the end there
wasn't a sound every person on this
stage looked at me and I sensed that
they accepted me as Batman before I
opened my mouth and we made it funny and
that was a wonderful moment that was the
magic of all of the baggage you know of
them the guys have worked with the
ladies too having read Batman that they
were aware of what that man was or did
and that they accepted my Batman and
that put me at ease a bit as a matter of
fact when you're playing Batman it's
like you can get away with anything
because Batman is such an innocent if
I'm creeping along a ledge and later on
we added Yvonne Craig is Batgirl and
she's behind me and Robin inspector
and I put my hand back here and see a
moment and I put my hand on her breast
and hold it there with a moment the
audience accepts him as the innocence
the naivete a Batman and then you know
with her reaction a bit but that's the
kind of guy once when Catwoman wants to
date or maybe marry Batman or something
he'll be compassionate because he has
curious stirrings in his utility belt
for you cat now
and then I'll say well maybe this is
chance to know we could get together
well when you get out of the joint when
you got out of jail you're on parole
maybe we can have a daters